so I posted on Instagram and Twitter about like
not being sure who I'm gonna vote for in the election
right because like
what the fuck is gonna happen November
I don't know obviously
obviously I do not want Trump
the way in which Democrats are going about talking about
you know  ðŸ‰ and Joe Biden's hand in it
like they're so divorced from reality
these guys literally in my reply saying
well I'm #freeðŸ‰ too
but like
we gotta vote for Joe Biden
it's like I don't think you guys understand that
like I'm watching every single day
like children that look like my family
like my cousins
I'm Arab like
people that look like they could be related to me
being murdered every single day
gside every single day
babies — every single day
children being disabled everyday
like I
this is not like a
you know like
a far away issue for me
I see these people and I'm like
they could be related to me
this is what my family looks like
this is just like a campaign talking point
like this is people's lives
this is people's lives
and there is such a callous disregard for people's lives
and such an inherent selfishness coming from their Democratic Party
sorry
that I am grappling with the moral decision of what I'm gonna do in November
because I cannot so easily dismiss the fact
that there are people being genocided in another country
at the hands of the United States government
because I don't wanna risk my quality of life doesn't mean that I want Trump
I know what Trump was
I spent the entire four years that he was president
talking about what Trump was doing
I'm very aware
the fact that despite that
I still have this much resistance towards Biden should tell you something
and everyone's like
well what about the Supreme Court
what about abortion
and it's like
what has happened under Biden
Biden has not done anything to help either of those issues
know what the Republicans wanna do if they win
obviously I don't want that
but the fact that y'all don't understand why this is so difficult and complex
and you think it's like this easy decision oh
I'm gonna vote for Biden
and guilting people into voting for Biden instead of pushing Biden to do better
is not gonna give you the outcome you want
look I truly think he's gonna lose regardless
because millions of people are feeling this way
and when he loses
it will not be the fault of the people that didn't vote for him
it will be the fault of Biden and the Democrats for not earning people's votes
for supporting this gside
this isn't just like some political talking point
these are people's lives
so I apologize if I'm still having this moral dilemma
but if you find it easy to just vote for the gsidal maniac
it means you don't really fully understand what is happening
this issue isn't actually impacting you the way that you think it is
and I have never felt this helpless in my entire life
and I wish that y'all would step away from your fucking keyboards
for a little bit
to understand
the actual human lives are being affected by this in ðŸ‰
it's not just this like
hot button topic that we're talking about on the internet again
these are my people
like these are Arab people
they're my people
angel to watch the way that you guys are speaking to Arab people